More than 10 million sport-related injuries occur every year. To prevent this,
both athletes and coaches use a number of warming-up exercises
to prevent injuries and improve performance. But what does science say about stretching
and warm up?
Many studies have looked at how racks affect sports performance and it appears that ...
it depends on the activity! Sports such as figure skating and snowboarding,
who must be able to make many different movements for a good assessment, will certainly benefit from it
to be flexible. But for strength sports such as skating and bobsleigh, too much can stretch
even lead to a temporary decrease in muscle strength. The overloaded muscle
becomes less taxable and can remain weakened for 30 minutes.
Although athletics competitions can be tiring, there is little evidence to claim that stretch
reduces muscle pain before or after a competition. Some studies have even found that
Extreme flexibility can lead to an enlargement of the area where you can stretch painlessly.
If you cannot feel the pain, the body does not know when you can go no further, and therefore
injuries can occur. Another major study of athletes showed that the least flexible and the most flexible participants
2.5 times as likely to have an injury. So when it comes to flexibility in competitive sport,
moderately flexible are optimal.
A good warm-up is also very beneficial. The term itself comes from the
positive effects of raising the temperature of your body before a competition.
Slowly increasing physical intensity prior to a sport increases muscle temperature, thereby ultimately
tighten your muscles. More powerful contractions means more power
and power. In addition, slowly moving more and more opens the blood vessels,
allowing blood to flow faster throughout the body, and it reduces the effort of the heart
Finally, as the blood temperature increases, your blood cells hold
less oxygen. This loose oxygen can then be used by the muscles, and so it becomes
increased endurance.
Science says it's important not to stretch, in terms of flexibility, but physically
Warming up the body for each specific sport might help
to win the competition.
Don't forget: we have a new video every day during the Olympic Games.
Can't you wait? Our wonderful colleagues from the CBC already have five videos to watch in one go.
Go to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to view them first. The link is in the description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use the hashtag #ScienceSays and let us know what your burning Olympic questions are.
And subscribe for more great videos!